i went to the prayer
for the sick service last week and you
preached about
god having principles for health i have
never seen those in reading the bible
what do you mean by that
the bible teaches us that our body is
god's temple
knowing not that he the temple of god
and that the spirit of god dwelleth in
you first corinthians 3 16
if any man defile the temple of god him
shall god destroy
for the temple of god is holy which
temple you are
now if we are children of god
we are holy
you have something against being holy if
we are children of
god we are holy amen after god calls
us to be holy now if we are
holy we must treat a holy thing
with great care now there are certain
things you will not do in your church
you will do them in the gym you won't do
them in the sanctuary
why sanchez holy
we take better care of church buildings
which will be destroyed when jesus comes
than we take of that place where the
holy spirit actually dwells in acts
seven
uh the uh stephens in his sermon says
the most high dwelleth not in temples
made with hands
some people come to church to meet god
if you don't bring him you're in trouble
god dwells right here and because of
this
the surroundings must be kept clean
and so in daniel chapter 1 verse 5 the
bible says and the king appointed them a
daily provision of the king's meat and
of the wine which he drank so nourishing
them three years that at the end thereof
they might stand before the king
nebuchadnezzar give these young boys a
special diet babylonian
but let me tell you something the best
food the world has to offer
is not good enough for a holy person
what's wrong with my people tonight i'll
help them out amen
thank you my good brother the best that
the world
has to offer is not good enough for a
child of god
and so when nebuchadnezzar the king the
highest man in the land
he gave them a royal diet daniel said
verse 8 but daniel purpose in his heart
that he would not defile his body with
the portion of the king's meat
nor with the wine which he drank
some adventists feel it's a classy thing
to drink wine
it's wrong there's nothing classy about
sin
there's nothing classy about defiling
your body daniel said no
and god honored him and the three hebrew
boys by giving them health in 10 days
some people take 10 years to get
this body must be protected
and cared for it is holy so don't smoke
amen it is holy don't tear up your liver
with alcohol
it is holy don't clog the arteries with
whatever clogs arteries
it is a holy it really is
and we must take that seriously
we die because of how we eat
heard someone say we dig graves with our
teeth
and we just tumble into it
our body is holy let's treat it that way
which means when i eat i should eat like
a christian
if i go to a restaurant on a thursday
how i select should reflect my holiness
you see
as a sabbath keeper i keep the sabbath
holy one day a week
but i am to be holy seven days a week
let me try that again without any help
from dr shives
i as a sabbath keeper i keep the sabbath
holy
one day a week i am to be holy seven
days a week
we are sabbath keepers seven days a week
because when we take our holiness with
us
and we're walking down the supermarket
aisle with the cart
you walk right past that shrimp go right
past the shrimp
go right past the lobsters go right past
the beef
because you're holy
go right past the wine
go right past the cigarettes
and go right past all the fatty stuff